well
um
inequality is really a
misconception and so are the policies
for dealing with it
um this idea of being unequal it's just
difference and it's a mistake to assume
that men and women want to do things in
the same way but if you're trying to
push forward a feminist agenda now what
would you counsel people who want more
equality to do what do the next stage be
sorry I just want to clarify something I
do not think men and women want to do it
in the same way good and then parent in
my experience quite differently often
than women do and women definitely work
differently than men do so I'm not
suggesting they're going to do it the
same way I'm suggesting and actually I
think it'd be better for raising
children if they had the different
models of how you raise children we
think we know how to raise children
because women have always raised
children but men do look at all the gay
men that are raising children and doing
it very well but so I don't think
they'll do it the same way that's not
that's not not what I'm saying okay men
and women do want to do things in
different ways good I'm glad we've got
to that so
that's very important
and so we're not trying we're not trying
to get a one-size-fits-all solution to
the workplace and to the family
okay then we might look at what females
prefer when they have the chance to
choose and that's I think what you were
talking about with the Nordic
um with the Nordic example
um that in Norway Sweden Denmark and so
on
women have very very good support for
looking after the children
etc etc the bottom line is they actually
don't want to go back to work full-time
in the way that women do in other
countries because they have to in the
states they have to go back to work full
time
in the Nordic countries they choose not
to and they are really happier that way
that's a choice
thank you Helena can I just Amanda
you've watched feminism do next very
briefly well very briefly
um I I side with Gloria Steinem who said
uh you have to know the truth
even if it pisses you off
so what is the truth here well the truth
is that today what I think we're talking
about are that women need to have
um
three things to have equality they need
to have agency
autonomy and Authority that means they
need to have the ability to make their
own decisions the capability to carry
them out and the control to be able to
stick to them the the good news is that
we've made enough progress in the 21st
century for that to be the case but the
bad news
the bad news is that
everything that we have achieved can be
taken away and history shows that again
and again in the 7th Century China women
were the most liberated in the world
they had a female prime minister a
female Empress they had a whole raft of
legal protections 600 years later China
is a divided country women have had
every single protection every single law
that gave them access to the public
space taken away and foot binding which
has crippled them for life has been
introduced today we are facing that same
kind of Challenge and the countries that
do not protect women's rights are poorer
more unstable more violent and more
culturally stagnant than the countries
that do and that is where the future of
feminism lies
oh
and for a quick recommendation for what
you do next with feminism a couple of
things I'd like to see you already know
My Views about race
um but I think in terms of History we've
heard a lot about history which I think
is crucial I I would love to see the
feminist movement not just acknowledge
that black women are an integral part of
feminism now but also acknowledge more
of the history for example we have the
suffragette film it was so disappointing
that that film neither acknowledged the
role that black people played in the
women's equality movement in that period
and also some of the allegiances that
were made between the suffragette
movement and racist segregationists
especially in America I'm not trying to
cast blame I think we need an honest
appraisal of our history so that we can
move forward and that's not happening at
the moment another thing I would like to
see since I'm hitting race I might as
well hit class I would like to see
feminism do more to acknowledge that not
all women are aspiring to be the next
CEO of Pepsi potentially because they're
not in the corporate world and a lot of
feminist books to me speak very much to
a specific context that even I don't
relate to let alone women who aren't in
as privileged a position as me and I
think that we still tend to see poor
women as other and not part of this
debate as we heard earlier I'm about to
go and report we were all having a
lively discussion about this in the
Green Room earlier on the full face Veil
and whether it should be banned in
schools and I think that without taking
aside on that particularly thorny debate
right now at the end I think that the
question of What Muslim women in
deprived communities do and the way it's
dealt with is often not acknowledging
their agency and I think that they
should be treated fairly as women in
this debate so I would like to see an
inclusiveness not just on Race but also
on class and I think that that is what
we need to strengthen the feminist
movement because as long as too many
women feel excluded or intimidated this
just remains an elite conversation and I
think that it's time for it to become
much more than that
Daniel I just want to discriminate
against you by asking you to talk just
for 30 seconds so we can get some
questions but I think you can live with
it I can live with it um so one really
specific thing I'm quite interested in
at the moment which makes me really
crazy uh neighbor upstairs had a baby is
going back to her big American law firm
in London has been told the classic
thing that if she comes back she can
only do the 60-hour weeks or nothing I
just think I'm not allowed to swear am I
but that is totally ridiculous
the idea that a big American firm can't
find us American a big Law Firm cannot
find a mechanism by which somebody a
woman or man can come back and work
roughly speaking the hours she wants to
work with or without the notice that she
does defies belief with the
organizational patterns we have with the
technology we have and the thing which I
really don't understand about and you
know perhaps you can explain to me
afterwards folks would it not be
advantageous for a law firm to say we're
the ones who crack that problem and you
can tell us when you come back from
whatever you've been doing how many
hours you want to work for whatever
reason and we'll fix that for you it
seems to make extraordinary that that
isn't offered anyway try to fix that one
that would be good
and Marie can do that no no there are
law firms that have done that but they
do different kind of work from the other
law firms and if women do want to work
in in those ways they choose the firms
that do that sort of work it's as simple
as that no big law is actually falling
apart because of that
successor I don't believe it
um could you I'd love to take some
questions um we're going to take them
three at a time can you please keep them
short but fascinating could we have the
lady there and this gentleman here and I
can't see any un lady in the middle of
the black sleeve please just just say
your name quickly if you would as well
um my name's Nadia and I study gender at
lse
um at a Master Level and I really
thought this was amazing conversation
and but one of the things I wanted to
note was Helena
um in terms of talking about men and
women being different I want to say of
course they're different because they're
conditioned to be as such because I have
to act differently
um to a man being friendly to me a man
being friendly to me as I would if a
woman was being friendly to me because
of the conditioning that I'm under I
have to identify as a woman because I
like in response to sexism not because
that dichotomy basically what I'm trying
to emphasize is the problem of dichotomy
and that that you've been speaking of
and reinforcing
um and I think
um what is important to focus on
intersectionality which is what Africa
you've been doing tonight and I think
what you've said is smashed it basically
and focusing more on Race trans
experience that's exactly what we must
do and because it is this dichotomy that
is provoking the inequality that we keep
reinforcing thank you thank you
um
hi I was going to ask actually about
intersectionality and class but ifua got
there right at the end and saved me from
having to do that instead I'd like to
ask how the panel responds to campaigns
such as we need to get a female
Secretary General of the UN or that if
we had more women in The Situation Room
there'd be less Wars and these things
that seem to be overtly feminist but
actually accentuate the difference
between men and women and play on
assumptions and I wondered how the panel
would respond to things like that thanks
thank you and lastly lady at the back
okay
that's you yes you
set my question's actually so your name
Julia
um in relation to Daniel's last comment
when you speak about hours I think
you've actually hit the jackpot because
in the UK and definitely my friends in
America would say that more hours equals
more productivity but what about if we
switched it the other way and said
actually we need this done and I don't
really mind if it takes less time I
think there'd be a lot more room for
women to actually say we could do that
and work out when they want to do it and
I just wondered what your view was that
as a whole
I like to go straight to Anne-Marie
thank you they're great questions
um because I know she's very hot on
hours and also what about the campaigns
to get women into senior roles and then
we'll I couldn't agree with you more on
ours essentially you know all the
research that I've read on productivity
and actually Henry Ford was the original
one who said after eight hours
productivity Falls and we have an eight
hour work day Sweden's introducing a six
hour work day when I see somebody who
stays till 10 o'clock routinely uh after
hours I I say I think you have a problem
with time management right and I think
you're not being very efficient because
I know other people can get the same
amount of work done and be out of the
office when they need to to do whatever
else they want so this is a culture it's
a culture of time Macho that is and it
is a competitive thing it's a very
competitive thing that says I work
better because I work longer when
everything we know about productivity
and about rest and about recharging and
and exposing yourself to things not the
same thing all the time says actually
working after a point uh working more is
actually producing less so so that point
on this very interesting question of you
know do I believe that a woman Secretary
of the General of the United Nations
would be more pacific no generally the
first woman in any of these jobs is more
male than the men because that's what
she's got to do uh to get there and to
prove it uh so I don't I don't I
wouldn't say that I'd say we need a
woman and preferably a woman of color
and and many different people because of
diversity of perspective but I would
also say that there's good social
science evidence that says once you hit
a critical mass of women in any group
not only do women feel free to express
what they really want to say and not
conform to what men they think they
should say but men's behavior changes
too because men feel like it's okay to
say what they want to say that Mega not
conform to very traditional definitions
of masculinity
thank you
hello
quick response to Nadia saying she feels
socially conditioned to respond in a
particular way over evolutionary time
there have been very different costs and
benefits to males and females of certain
kinds of behavior
for example it did no damage to males to
to have lots and lots of sex with lots
of different women but for women it
would have been a huge disadvantage to
have sex with any man not just sorry no
you could talk to Helena afterwards but
I'm just giving you I'm just giving you
an example it's a very extreme example
of the difference of costs and benefits
in different behaviors to men and women
and I think what you're picking up on
are innate differences probably between
men and women in the costs and benefits
of those behaviors over our
revolutionary past and it's absolutely
ridiculous to assume that all behaviors
were neutral for both sexes that is not
so in any sexually reproducing species
whatsoever for the last 800 million
years
and it's not suddenly true of ours can
we take three more questions please
um
gentleman here uh a lady right at the
back on the uh of that far block
do you have to hand up with a long hair
and the black and the black top
and
um a lady here at the end of the room
would you whoever gets a mic first
please
um
cake greasing
um given so many of the protagonists
that have come up in this discussion are
American women be their Gloria Steinem
or Emory Slaughter or Cheryl Sandberg
I'm fascinated and yes this is not with
American accent for and and Marie's
perspective on where is America ahead of
the UK and what could we learn to help
our British women be more aggressive and
competitive without being judged to be
either
whoever's got the mic next
hi and my name is Emily um I just have a
quick question in terms of what's next
um I work with Brands a lot I work for
brand consultancy and I'm just
interested in the context of huge
companies like Unilever PepsiCo who are
really working on their social purpose
and social missions what do you think is
the next step for Brands how can they
help feminism be more inclusive or the
things we've been saying this evening
thank you thank you
thank you I'm Dan reinstein um obviously
the the issue uh that you all do agree
with is equality and I think Ms Hirsch
put it the best in terms of equality of
opportunity and then nature might
determine the the final pathway you know
when I walked in here the first thing I
noticed was that
um 97 of the audience is women
and I just wonder what you think whether
one of the things which is next for
feminism is to completely Rebrand it and
call it equalism not feminism because
many guys especially younger guys don't
want to be called feminine
and somehow I think it's a it's a it
there's a branding issue with that in
that it it feminizes men to think that
they're going to be
feminists and I I wonder what you think
about that marketing is everything
thanks Dan maybe you've answered Emily's
question about branding um and Marie I
feel this is
this is very much your territory uh well
so yes well I was just on the on the
first question
um so you know Britain is the head of
the United States in many many ways
let's just start with the fact the
United States does not have mandatory
maternity leave right we we and Papua
New Guinea let me just say that again we
and Papua New Guinea are the only two
countries in the entire world out of 194
Nations that do not think that when a
woman has a child she should actually
have some time to recover from the birth
and feed the child so
Britain's way ahead
but there is the United States is ahead
in terms of the number of women at the
top now part of that actually Helena
said you know when you have to go back
to work so fast you stay in uh and there
there are more women at the top at the
very top and the U.S and Sweden are tied
for 22 women in Senior Management but
the Nordic countries do not have free
choice by a long shot my article was as
uh picked up in the Nordic countries as
anywhere else and they still think
they've got a long way to go I I don't
think that we want to convince British
women to be more aggressive and
competitive I think actually the way to
the way Britain is is tackling this is
to say look you should be able to work
part-time and still be on leadership
track right you should be that you make
room for ways in which women and men can
care for their children and then don't
waste that talent and then you'll have
of women in the pool so I I think the
U.S is doing better in some ways but I'm
not sure the lesson uh is is to be more
more aggressive and on the rebranding
you you know you just stole my closing
statement so I think I'm going to ask
you to wait
okay Amanda wanted to come in on that
well just uh going to the point about
hours uh which leads us to the next
thing which is child care
and there is never going to be gender
equality in the workplace until women no
longer have to pay the work tax known as
paying for childcare out of your
post-tax income
that is one of the single biggest
impediments to all women who have
children and I have five children so I
know where off I am talking
didn't us want to respond to that
equalism well that was just about the
child my assumption in households where
men and more than women it's always
seemed to me more natural that you
should take child care costs from the
bigger salary not the smaller one and
once you've done they have a natural
some relationships
um I do want to say in terms of role
models and the Secretary General of the
United Nations and one of the things so
I take my kids to school every morning
um and if I'm not out doing fabulous
things like this I'm back by six and
bath them
um and I make sure I tell that to all of
the young people and people I speak to
because I think it's really important
that people assert that it's possible to
be the director of what will be London's
most exciting engagement space when it
opens next year
without without sacrificing family life
for yourself and I also think that we
have to find ways in which
um you know women can take that role um
and and assert their ability to do it
too it doesn't seem to me that it's an
either or we have to have success models
the only thing is a neurobiologist I
would say is that the categories that
we're talking about uh and the
plasticity that gives rise to them is
different at different ages so I am
quite protective it seems to me I think
we should be quite protective of the
environment which younger people
certainly up to the age of seven eight
nine when a lot of these categories are
formed are exposed to and again for me
the solution in Britain and I will say
this over America is CBeebies right I
mean the idea that there is a television
station which is kind of thought a lot
of this through seems like a really
good idea so on race and on gender on
the way they're prepared their portrayed
I have confidence that my kids can watch
that up to a certain age and they will
be given exposure to stuff like that and
again as a neuroscientist I'm pleased
with that because they can do kind of
what they like after the age of nine in
these terms but these categories are
formed early so I do think we have to be
quite careful about the category to
which while very young are exposed to
and their tokenism and equality or
equity in that sense seems to me quite a
good idea as a prescribed nation and I
should say Teletubbies was gender fluid
yes it was
[Applause]
[Laughter]
um
I'm going to have to ask the panel now
to just tell us each um in a minute or
so how do you which is exactly the
question that Dan was raisingly how do
you get all kinds of people on board
with this agenda the people in this room
have probably already sold on it but how
do you persuade the women who think that
feminism has nothing to do with them
which is 93 of the population from what
we know 90 of the female population and
all the men who think that permanent
isn't something which some weird women
want to engage in that actually this is
in their interests
um and I'm going to start off with
asking Helena to give them her summary
about how he convince people
well feminism began by opposing an
injustice women being denied Choice
solely because they were women
but this really admirable Quest became
derailed by an obdurate refusal to
acknowledge that there are real sex
differences
the good news is that a feminism
informed by the darwinian science of
human nature both male and female
reveals a very much more promising World
I'll just give you two examples
first what constitutes success
men and women have different life
priorities
so why should male priorities the
pursuit to the top for money and power
and fame typically male priorities why
should they be the sole yardstick
science illuminates why there are
multiple paths to fulfillment
including the broader priorities that
women in particular value
second what constitutes equality and
fairness equality is not sameness we
shouldn't expect male and female choices
to be identical we shouldn't say it's
wrong if they're not differential
interests lead to differential
trade-offs and so to differential
outcomes these differences are not
evidence of discrimination or lack of
meritocracy fairness involves not
denying difference but understanding the
consequences of them so it's not sex
differences but sexism that should be
challenged and not science but Injustice
that should be opposed and just as a
last Point science doesn't dictate goals
it doesn't but it can help us to achieve
our goals it must because if we want to
change the world we first need to
understand it we don't try to build
planes but refuse to understand
aerodynamics so how can feminism Forge a
fairer world if it lacks a proper
understanding of how the Sexes differ
Elena thank you we're going to have up
our next
a big issue I think in why feminism
affects everybody is mediocrity there
are a lot of mediocre men in senior
positions and I think it was Warren
Buffett who said that I got off really
lightly because I only had to compete
with half of the pool of people who I
could have been up against in my career
and um I didn't respond to the questions
but in response to the great question
about whether affirmative action is kind
of reinforcing essentialist Notions the
reason it's important to have women in
the boardroom or in the control room is
because if you are competing genuinely
with the entire pool of talent to people
you just get fewer mediocre people in
senior positions and that is to the
benefit of everyone in society as far as
I'm concerned
um I think that feminism it does have a
an image problem but I I don't think
it's just a question of changing the
name I think we need to look at the root
causes as I've said why people feel
intimidated or alienated by feminism and
part of that as I said earlier I think
is being more honest about the history
of feminism and being more inclusive
about the future
I think a reason that men are to benefit
from feminism is because it's simple
progress when we're talking about hours
that the lack of productivity at work
the culture that we have I think
everywhere in the world where you want
to be in before your boss and leave
after him usually him which I see all
the time it it kind of destroys my soul
to see young people spending their lives
doing something for the sake of being
seen at the expense of their
productivity and their dreams I think
it's a damaging practice and I think
that women are the ones at the moment
who are forcing that to change and I
think everybody stands to benefit from
that and finally just in response to the
question about what can brands do to
help feminism stop using women's bodies
to sell everything period
thank you
Daniel
I'm not saying that
feminist problems or the problems that
feminists focus on are the Canary and
the coal mine but it has it seems to me
increasingly that the issues where
feminism is alarmed I think of perhaps
women in Tech particularly
um give Clues to situations which are
inefficient and unjust and should be
changed so the reason we should care
about feminism is because it's quite an
efficient way of detecting sub-optimal
human behavior the tech industry is
struggling it feels to me to embrace
what is human and seriously they're
selling US problems to solutions to
problems that most of us don't have like
how to do sociability without eye
contact and part of that which is
essentially what we've been sold and and
that's uh taking place in a situation
which has amongst the most horrifying
figures in terms of women in the
workplace and their treatment so I think
feminism is something should concern us
all because it shines a light on things
we could do better and to improve
ourselves as humans we should focus on
those areas
thank you
Amanda how do we how do we say one well
I think that is a key question and it's
what I want to address which is you know
what's in it for the men and
Lennon said
um he said the success of every
Revolution depends on the participation
of women and he's absolutely right if
you look at all revolutions go back to
the French Revolution it's when women
joined the Vanguard that the old order
collapsed and a new order came in but
those very women who fought for change
were always betrayed by the male leaders
of that Revolution always until you had
a woman-led revolution in the 20th
century and why is that that's because
on the whole male revolutions male lead
ones are about changing the power
structure from one one power level to
the other power level it's about
oppositions and that's it whereas when
women fight for a revolution
they want to dismantle that power
structure in order to bring in
egalitarianism
and that's why feminism is good for men
as well as women because it brings in
genuine equality
of course
how are you going to change the world so
I'm going to leave you with a few very
simple prescriptions in terms of what
what we can do
so we can stop talking about mothers and
start talking about parents
every time you want to say mother stop
say parents and children
parents and family
stop talking about daughters and start
talking about caregivers or in Britain
carers carers for parents whether
they're Sons or daughters
stop talking about fathers
and start talking about earners or
providers
both men and women
start assuming that every
everybody men and women want some
combination of the ability to invest in
themselves and to invest in others
everyone
and that all workers all employees
will have caregiving responsibilities at
some point in their lives and a
competitive effective workplace
efficient productive we'll make room for
that kind of care
and start assuming that investing in
others is every bit as important and
rewarding and valuable as investing in
ourselves
and finally I don't think I would call
it equalism I think egalitarianism is
better but maybe isms are not the way to
go
what we are looking for is a world in
which we don't assume everyone is the
same absolutely not but a world in which
our assumptions about who someone is and
what they want and what they can achieve
and what their potential is is not tied
to their sex or their gender or their
sexual orientation
anymore than it is tied to the shape of
their features or the color of their
skin